that was my fault
I'd understand
but who knew they'd feel better than
nobody knows it would be something to
like join the posse
it's employment might be some 20 euros
basically uh-oh
is that because I screwed up I didn't
screw up there
I didn't I press the right button there
we just wanted to hang that means that
was gonna happen no matter what she's
not she didn't she don't [ __ ] it wasn't
a great idea
this is chapter nine two hours till
German Shepherd that's why I'm thinking
at this point in the game lost others in
very serious to win he's back to the
sanatorium again oh did he go through
the tunnel
well he's looking for Josh Amy myself
Jesus man was he features okay okay I'm
thinking there was another totem I'm
just gonna look at again I don't know
what you're talking about was it I think
it might have been a danger to him
actually that has Mike moving away from
a wall back that's in the sanatorium
look for yeah brick is this brick on
yeah I know there's two things like
hanging from the ceiling like anything
perhaps I can't get through those
they're not inside building
notice that yeah but I mean I don't know
I feel like I'm just gonna be right this
is originals
that's my in a sanatorium but that
happens yeah - yeah that's big that hand
yeah I don't know exactly where it is
here not just all walls just avoid well
that's Jake Hart middle plateau which
way because now I'm just so worried
about [ __ ] walls listen this is a big
open spaces of the deep
so we're looking for Josh
yeah why would you ashamed Josh came
here of all places and more it's a
winter going God's can't go in a
building why would they take Josh inside
a building they can't go in buildings
there was nothing written there huh see
okay administration there was nothing
written there to say that no no no but
we are going daylight well and we
haven't seen that and they can't break
through buildings they can't break glass
which is weird they couldn't break the
door down
well they just didn't we they just
didn't want to perhaps because maybe
they can't see the movement when you're
inside building perhaps so you just go
visible yeah but I don't you know I
don't think that we should dare to shoot
it just if they cannot get inside does
it make sense it's like with this place
is a [ __ ] maze I don't know this
could take forever
this place isn't is amazing we don't
have any Josh your voices so we have no
idea where we're going it's a bit weird
ah why the hell not here
what what
we don't want to go on is that there's
that guy still you
this my baby suit Meredith you know
start citing follow diet citing guilt so
the net could be interesting
this is almost it says why is this this
is the same guy I think you died with
the wolves I think is our flamethrower
guy because you know it says Elias local
mountain I'm dead equals and a so this
is the wolf's can fight the window guys
do you think probably yeah but I think
on June
today we know we just died yeah I say to
you looked like human hands but it
sounds like an animal it was windy car
you certainly went to go yeah yeah
that's meted maybe there's a key
somewhere two minute - good that's
really strange
you can't go through that way though no
it's just so why is he saying holy [ __ ]
I walked in here this is that same room
what's a little room does of different
to have looked before
it wasn't trash before wasn't I think so
I kind of doing that that title there
was handcuffs
yeah it's just this ago
see ya that this is the same guy so we
can confirm that this guy was also they
were just I all movie that with someone
to go and I but I think it's I think
just the only bad guy be innocent who
killed Jess was a Wendigo yes well the
first thing yeah it was definitely went
to go so I'm thinking that the only
enemies in this game a Wendigo nothing
else only anything else about anything
maybe the guy who controls the wolves
he's not a bad guy
no I think he's the same guy I think the
Wolves probably can choose I think I
might throw a guy was the down
controlled wolves and I think yeah yeah
they walk differently I don't know well
I've seen him it's all tied together
this cigar is the same thing was in the
mind truth over the name and stuff same
guy like this is all his stuff like that
map it's a bias you know I think it's
the same guy it's just that it was
animated differently you like to make
him look more creepy but before he
became an ally or whatever living we
could spend [ __ ] hours in yeah walking
around I don't know when I can hear the
radio you're getting into that one
decision into that
yes okay I think my could very well die
but probably not by dropping down
shotgun shook up take it take it take it
when you take this instead of the
shuffle
oh you know that's right they don't like
flying
yeah yeah good did he kill him
and then it's not good but he said you
know like a [ __ ] shotgun come on of
course well it's mine it's mine it's my
tease be nice all about birds
he's not that chopper it is actually a
very nice round up yeah fancy pizza yeah
all right she's very well-equipped
missing two fingers but so he's gonna
get infected so bad after all this all
right
yeah we're pretty too much of these
reasons for something else here
but we haven't been me sergeant
don't let it get in there do we have to
go up against pity
nobody not sure yeah that's what my dose
I'm that close you [ __ ] leave okay
Mike so Mike like it is very Mike don't
hurt I'm good getting mad at me because
I kicked it don't be cross is you yes
but that butterfly effect' update said
this is a negative outcome because of
this yeah because he hid this since it
is fun but this don't want ya cuz I so
fall but anyway I think I just looked
the dopes not wild the dog was with the
other dogs with feet done yeah who is
she nice Victor yeah never introduced
himself warning this area is closed off
eventually danger of death sounds great
let's do it did he kill you with the
doll I don't know show me the dumb one
but he doesn't like something he's seen
in here blue is it's creepy just
announced a visit South brick area
what are those streets or therefore is
annoying camera angle what do you
don't lock me in first so that's great
I'd be a security thing always looking
for Josh this is ridiculous
why would you even be here okay well why
would he be why would they bring you
muna you're right back in brick yeah in
brick it was straight it wasn't wasn't
don't know that I'm wondering if it's
gonna be in this room that I'm looking
to could be well dude stop thinking
about it could be anywhere yeah to teach
leader yes very good looked all right I
want to do it right I wasn't really
think we should be going left
Oh what's hot that's dead wonder go
how would it be dead should I - it well
simply a way to go and say yeah no no
it's no art wendi-go i careful it's
gonna spatula probably something else
looks like bad yeah when you wanna go
left or right
let's go dick
because they were to keeping Windigo
well things conspiracy I'm sorry inside
there okay that's fresh
alright it's cool which I'm very worried
about Mike is you sit I think it won't
happen to that one
I think so too I think it's gonna be a
cutie could be tweets they need to be
prepared don't the [ __ ] Mike what a
shitty camera angle can't see anything
let me jump out to Naraku yes it's about
time is nothing it's we go ahead this
yeah it's white to sedate yeah the least
the jokes guys are like easily
digestible like they happen and then you
should move on you know we know is it's
gonna happen yeah it's too quiet
everything those things hanging Jerry
what yeah I can't see that
[ __ ] camera angles it wasn't even
scary
it's quite here on the outside of this
building I don't know what do you want
on it it's still on the outside of the
building I still just here look at the
Josh for some [ __ ] reason like Josh
will be in a sanatorium ladder gives me
a lot of time the first is all right
keep running keep running middle level
straight ahead left straight hit ways to
keep slicing shut doors people eating he
does know he goes oh okay it quick quick
quick
yeah a little bit faster than that Oh
learn rich I'm initial things with a
shotgun when he looked at a lot why not
yeah there's no downside to it are you
just wasting bullets yeah but I can't
use them on anything else but when you
know I said why would I not use the one
way to go oh [ __ ] that's fun that's not
hard
this is not good then I like flying
watch yourself Mike you go back that way
okay if that's what you really want my
have no idea does he
nothing see that my concern is
flashbacks I think those are like you
made a bad decision with that is really
yeah I'm sorry this ain't bad decision
but it's saying you know a decision lot
they're everywhere yeah you stay still
too
he wasn't there when they found out that
moving he switched
what are you even doing here Mike I'm so
mad at you this looks like it yeah
did you sell today don't no idea what I
swear right now what
I don't know what he sees just talking
to himself why don't my till this does
the job scared scared
it's a lot like fun badgering angry
young with it [ __ ] you a thing - totem
[ __ ] so yeah this this whole thing is
one big conspiracy this isn't even under
Silas is to try and contain the when you
go to buy you'll swim round I mean this
place has been shut down for a long time
right well I'm pretty glad very happy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I feel like I could choose yes I
can't do anything until this is prompt
you like as your buddy you have to do it
buddy here's the thing we certain dials
telephone line up it wasn't you know at
all where is he now
lock that door yes right do a lot more
creepy [ __ ] no more creepy [ __ ] still
obvious whatever trance isn't it was he
by himself
wait - get this I don't get why he said
because Josh I have no idea
Josh last we saw Josh who's being
dragged through the snow what's that -
nyle and I missed while he was like
maybe we were talking and then there was
something that we missed perhaps but
maybe I mean Victor said he liked taking
a mere assumption because right now I
just think I don't believe it
to sit in this is like the second time
he's done this [ __ ] I'm like you get
your [ __ ] together Mike there's so many
other places you could be right now
namely with all your friends you know
laughter's safe whoa no you want it
[ __ ] bed instead of jewelry begin
with those little bones truth I want to
do this [ __ ] zombies [ __ ] oh just do
this she wants the key from Josh but I
don't I feel like you know part of being
a hero you have to be at least a little
bit small to save people he's supposed
to be intelligence well wondering get a
common one to their benefit I'm not that
scared then I'm gonna know that there's
key teams and stuff but I'm not that
rare schism essentially it's not this
but whatever reason I don't think that
might deny you
if there are one of them they might
never be like it
that's right lessons I just really don't
like together
what Chile yeah yeah well if Josh's a
man he's a crisp because Josh will be in
there [ __ ] try I'm so mad at you my
head it was such a waste of time that's
like when when they died spirit gets
released or something what he said
that's right